hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played last year in
December in the video World rapid
Championship you guys requested the
scene now a few more games by another
big hablusato of the board one uh star
player of Uzbekistan who now won the
feed HS Olympiad and I thought okay
we've shown a couple of games from the
world rapid Championship but we've shown
his game against Magnus I think from uh
niponishi and maybe maybe one more uh
not not really sure but we have not
shown his game against Fabiano Corona
and Abdul sattro as you guys know or
maybe some of you don't is the reigning
world rapid champion and uh to attain
this title he defeated pretty much
everyone he defeated karwana here he
defeated Carlson he defeated he defeated
he defeated the Boris Golf and he
defeated uh he defeated pretty much
anyone who was there to defeat and he
rightfully I won the title but this is
one game that we haven't shown from that
event and like I said as you guys
requested to see more games it's really
really a wonderful one because at that
time okay he was strong but no one
really expected him to win and no one
really thought that he could play play
against us as such strong players but
here he shows you exactly why he can so
here we have pawned the C4 he opens with
the English opening and fabigos Ponte E5
The King's English variation uh Knight
the C3 and now Bishop to B4 The Chronic
hero counter attack we have knighted D5
again immediately attacking the bishop
and Bishop back to E7 we have Pawn to D4
Pawn to D6 challenging the E5 uh
defending the E5 Pawn Knight to F3 and
now Fabi advances the Ponte E4 end
attacks this Knight here Knights the D2
We have Fanta C6 chasing away the Knight
and now we trade Knight captures Queen
captures and now Knight the B1 very very
impressive stuff but this is all
standard Theory but quite a journey for
this Knight coming from from G1 to B1 uh
Knight to F6 and now Knight the C3 we
have castles and now uh there were a
couple of games back then uh when where
Bishop to G5 was played but here with
Bishop the four by another break and it
is now as of move 10 that we have a
completely new game so far he goes for
the bishop uh right away with night
stage five with Bishop back to D2 and
now Pawn to F5 grabbing more space here
and if F4 is allowed then yeah another
back will be in a lot of trouble so he
plays E3 uh seemingly uh F4 is still
possible but for the moment your knight
is hanging so you have to attend to that
Knight back to F6 and now Bishop to E2
continuing development preparing the
castle Bishop to E6 and now we have
Queen the B3
uh not really doing all that much as B7
is defended and also the bishop is an E6
uh but it is a tricky move to uh to meet
and here uh best for Fabi would be
something like A5 bring the queen over
to F7 to put more pressure on uh on the
queen here and then execute B5 or you
could execute B5 immediately it is
possible but Fabi decides not to do this
he goes Knight to A6 now he wants to
bring the Knight to C7 Castles by uh
another week and now Knight to C7 and
here he gives um a deadly there uh can
he capture the opponent B7 uh it looks
like it will be incredibly dangerous but
uh dosatro shows that he is not afraid
and he calculates everything precisely
Queen characters on B7 the sort of
poison Pawn is captured and now Rook 8
to B8 attacking the queen and indeed if
you go for the A7 Pawn for example Queen
captures then your queen gets captured
here Rook 8 Queen B7 Rook after B8 and
now you no longer have any Square after
main characters here Rook to A6 you have
no more squares for your queen and your
queen will be lost however after Rook
ate the V8 he plays Queen captures and
C6 and okay now Rook captures on B2
Fabio gains one of his pawns back and
now Bishop to C1 as the bishop on D2 is
hanging so Bishop to C1 Chasing The Rook
back we have Rook the B6 attacking the
queen and now Queen to A4
uh now again putting pressure on the
pawn here uh so Rook F to B8 uh offering
the pawn and while you could capture
this uh here another brick shows that
like morphe uh he is not a butcher he is
an artist and he plays Pawn the C5 and
pawn to C5 is a really really classy
move uh and uh you will of course find
out why fear Fabi plays D captures on C5
and now uh there are many moves that you
could play in the position but there is
only one move that wins the game for Abu
satrov so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find this idea while I
give you a couple of seconds
foreign
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
maneuver and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Bishop to
A3 and this is uh the idea uh we give up
a pawn back temporarily and now we will
claim it back with the threat of just
Bishop captures and C5 that will win a
whole lot of material so here Fabi moves
the queen offers the queen trade and
Abdul satrov says no problem let's trade
Queens Bishop captures on C5 I'm still
up a pawn and now Fabi plays Rook the B2
if you trade Queens nothing good is
really happening you just agreed to play
a worse position Knight captures now
attacks The Rook uh and you're still
down upon you really have nothing uh to
to show for in this position so instead
we have rooked the B2 the Queens will
get traded off but at least fabino gets
in active Rook on B2 and now we have uh
Queen characters
um on these seven Knight captures on D7
and now Bishop back to A3 not allowing
The Rook to remain on such an active
square and well you could go Rook to C2
then we play something like Rook F to C1
Fabi goes back Rook to B6 and now Rook F
to C1 again absolute strongest from
Abdullah of putting pressure on that
undefended Knight on C7 uh so we could
move this Knight and then uh the Knight
on z7 will be in trouble so Fabi plays
Rook the C6 but this really doesn't help
him abdusader just captures an E4 and it
looks weird because now there's a rook
on C6 but it doesn't matter if the Rook
captures it then we're gonna capture
with the a rook and the Knight will
still be hanging so it's a free Pawn so
Rook captures on C1 check Rook captures
uh we have F characters on e4 and now
Rook captures on C7 luckily we have our
Bishops so you don't have to worry about
any back rank mates from Rook to B1 Fabi
does go for this with check but now just
Rook the C1 Abdul satram is very
confident in playing the same game
against Fabi Rook captures on C1 Bishop
captures and now Bishop captures on A2
Fabi gains one of his pawns back but he
is still down upon and Abdul satrov does
have the bishop fair so can he win this
the position is objectively winning but
uh he has to play a very very precise
moves and here he starts with the bishop
to A3 uh we have King to F7 Fabi starts
bringing his King into the game and now
King the F1 uh maybe a bit more precise
would be Bishop to B4 simply preventing
this Pawn from going to A5 it's a pass
Pawn so you know uh it cannot go to A6
and also if it can go to A5 then that
will be good for you but it's a rapid
game of course you can't have all the
time in the world to decide such things
so King to F1 now comes spawn to A5 Fabi
immediately takes advantage of this
bishop to B5 now attacking the Knight
also guarding A4 and Knight to B6 with
King to E1 and now Bishop to C4 so Fabi
uh kind of claws his way back into the
game uh we have Bishop to C6 Abdul satro
would very much enjoy keeping his Bishop
pair but now Bishop to D5 and now if
Abdus absor doesn't want trade five we
will just repeat and save the game but
uh it is uh not yet time for such things
so Bishop captures Knight captures and
King to D2 still uh it's a position
where Abu satra is up upon King to E6
with Bishop to f8 putting pressure on
the pawn here G6 and now Pawn to F3 uh
having a beautiful Center here but his
E3 Pawn is now a little bit weak so the
king can't really move from D2 King to
F7 going after the bishop and the now
comes Bishop to D6 it was uh basically a
dare here Fabi is asking do you want to
play Pawn characters on e4 uh but I I I
I I I can't really remember and I didn't
have options of checking this uh if
abdusadra was incredibly low on time but
here instead of going for King to seven
you could play some like into F5 but
still it's incredibly difficult to hold
this father played King to F7 and now
comes the bishop to D6 he doesn't go for
the trade but if you guys are interested
ESF captures and E4 was a winning point
being that if the uh pieces get traded
off captures captures this is of course
winning for white white is up two points
there's no question about this you
simply defend one of your pawns and you
go collect at this Pawn this is a very
very simple stuff so I imagine abusatra
was incredibly low on time here and he
is playing Fabiano Corona so Bishop to
D6 was played now King E6 and now ah he
goes for it uh F captures an E4 which is
a bit weird as you would prefer your the
black ink to be further away from the
action but he shows that it still works
now of course if you capture this we're
just gonna play captures on D5 and this
is objectively winning King D3 we push
over the black king we control for
example a4e for you you control all of
these squares you're just gonna collect
the pawn and there's no way for the
black ink to attack any of the the two
uh Central white pawns so here at night
6 Fabi keeps the pieces into the game
now King D3 we have A4 starting to push
the pass Pawn but now Bishop to A3 we
have Knights the G4 putting pressure on
the pawn here now D5 check King to E5
and the bishop the B2 check King to D6
in here abdulsatro just played H3 and it
was in this position animal 46 that
Fabiana corvana resigned the game and a
wonderful wonderful victory for another
Abdullah in round three of the uh feeder
World rapid Championship 2021 so here
just to give you an example of how
simple this is once the Knight moves and
there really aren't all that many
squares where you can go to
uh Bishop covers this if you go if you
go Knight to F2 you're just all the way
back from the action so let's say Knight
H6 we're gonna play King D4 now we're
just gonna start pushing those pawns
let's say Knight F7 E5 comes with check
uh and this is a very tricky move
because if Knight captures you're just
gonna play Bishop to A3 check and
collect the Knight so it uh there's no
way of actually doing this King E7 E6
which is with the Knight again if you go
here then we just uh attack the knight
uh completely winning let's say you go
here now we just got bashup A3 checking
has to go out on board King E5 G5 now
whatever you play doesn't really matter
King F6 Knight B7 and now we start
pushing Pawn to D6 H6 Pawn to D7 check
King to d8 King F7 and of course now
this is a game over so I know you guys
enjoy it when I uh finish the games as
sometimes you know you uh uh it might be
trickier to win an end game then it
would seem at first uh so yeah really
really wonderful game by Abdul satro of
it all came down to this moment where
Fabi said uh you know I don't uh I don't
uh I believe that you are as good as you
appeared to be and he played this Knight
the C7 idea basically the whole Knight
A6 the C7 idea uh doesn't really hold as
the B7 pawn it never was never really
poisoned but Abdullah rose up to the
challenge capture the pawn and he uh he
he showed us that uh Fabi never really
had anything there he had an active play
and he had ideas but with perfect play
it was uh very very much insufficient uh
so yeah once again really hope you guys
enjoyed this if you are interested in a
couple of other Abdullah of games if
you've only started watching chess uh
maybe during the Olympiad then I will
put a playlist of the world rapid
Championship 2021 in the description
below first thing you will see so you
can check it out there are a couple of
Abdul Saturn of games like his game
against the Magnus Carlsen and the
animation there are both of the games
against the animation as uh yeah they
also went into tie break so they had
play a few games more and there are a
couple of Crossing games there so you
might enjoy that as well and always
there is the Bobby Fischer playlist in
the description below will be the second
link if you guys haven't watched the
Bobby Fischer Saga uh feel free to do
that as well uh so yeah that's the game
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Keith Singh Kathleen Althea
Cashman Robert arathon cold feet and
Reckless spawn for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day